auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
[Musik]
kühne pläne cornelia betsch medion
jean-marie suter wurden in marokko eine
kleine feriensiedlung bauen
neues leben neues glück die familie
händler übernimmt den schwedisch
lappland eine hotel und campinganlage
und auf und davon in ein neues abenteuer
mit kamelen zieht die familie blum durch
das australische outback
[Musik]
am morgen ist familienhund brian der
glücklichste vierbeiner schwedens dann
hat er sein herrchen max ganz für sich
allein
max henzler ist eigentlich ein richtiger
morgenmuffel und doch liebt er die höhe
der frühen stunden wenn die feriengäste
noch schlafen macht er seine erste runde
und genießt seine neue schwedische
heimat in vollen zügen
[Musik]
das super dass ich das ist
außergewöhnlich ist ganz speziell für
das ist ganz wichtig für
manchen allgemein für mich speziell ich
habe gemerkt dass der boden gibt und die
wurzeln
heute ist der längste tag des jahres und
die henzlers feiern ihr erstes mit
sommerfest
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
lernte sabrina bluhm schießen
und die abenteurer spannten zum ersten
mal die kamele vor den wagen
in marokko warteten cornelia und schon
harry noch immer auf die baubewilligung
auch der besuch im gouverneurssitz
stimmte die beiden nicht
zuversichtlicher
in schweden wollte alles perfekt machen
ich muss das lernen
und er überforderte sich dabei ziemlich
[Musik]
ein fall für familien hund brian
gut
[Musik]
bei ihrem umzug nach schweden ging
vieles drunter und drüber nun aus dem
leben der familie henzler ein wenig ruhe
eingekehrt
[Musik]
sein rufname geschaffen auch nichts
patient macht ja
und die aber nur noch willst du den job
dennoch spaß hätte sich und die anderen
bin ich froh dass der film auch hier ist
81 prozent familienbetrieb
[Applaus]
telefon max ist ein mann mit 1000 ideen
die er jedoch selbst mit seinem großen
tatendrang nicht alle umsetzen kann
[Musik]
schrauben
seit kurzem unterstützen so genannte
work wales die familie händler
ihre heutige aufgabe den festball für
die große feier herrichten zu
machen
workers sind reisende aus der ganzen
welt die für kost und logis arbeiten
dank ihnen hat max wieder etwas mehr
luft und auch zeit für seine kinder
[Musik]
in australien laufen die letzten
vorbereitungen für den großen wüsten
trip der familie blum
gegen sonne und wind hat sabrina
vorhänge genäht nun scheint alles bereit
zu sein
der wagen wird für drei monate
schutzhaus und fortbewegungsmittel für
die familie sein
300 liter wasser und lebensmittel wie
teigwaren gemüse kartoffeln mehl und
zucker sind geladen
vier dieser kanäle werden den wahren
ziehen ein halbes jahr lang sind die
wüstentiere von sabrina und markus
trainiert worden nun haben sie vertrauen
gefasst und sind startklar für die große
reise
eigentlich wäre alles perfekt wenn nur
die besitzer der kamele nicht wehren das
anfänglich freundschaftliche verhältnis
zwischen den blues und den besitzern des
kamelhof hat sich merklich abgekühlt
nur was die gründe dafür sind darüber
rätselt selbst sabrina
ja
mit
mit den eltern oder wohnen
sie sehen oder so aber sie ein totales
anders
weltbild vor
als mir und ich bin sehr sehr negativ
und das ist
und ich noch nie erlebt aber das liegt
das extrem von markus am markt sehr viel
treiben immer wohl
ich sehe sie einfach eskaliert
wo
fries völlig aus der luft
es scheint als zweifelten die kamel
besitzer grundsätzlich an den
fähigkeiten der blues
für ihn dass ich einfacher sowie
fahrzeuge bedeuten ich glaube das hat
extrem aus
bis
es war ein treffer
[Musik]
cornelia breitschmid und schon marie
sutter sind unterwegs im marokkanischen
hinterland
das nähen reagiert dieses stück land
steht für einen großen traum eine eigene
feriensiedlung mit acht gästehäusern und
swimmingpool wollten die aargauer hier
bauen doch dieser traum ist geplatzt
die marokkanischen behörden vertrösteten
die auswanderer mal um mal so lange bis
die beiden ihr projekt zurückzogen ihr
projekt das sie so sehr liebten das
zahlt da er aber
nötig -
letztere der kwk und
aber das land jetzt ich hätte gesagt das
land das sind minibar im und so daniel
gros tage nötig mehr steiner war
zurück in ihre wohnung in der vorstadt
von ihrer
liebe empfängerin leben empfänger
unseres dritten newsletters im leben
gibt es zeichen welche beanspruchen gut
interpretiert und gedeutet zu werden das
ist ja sooo sexy cornelia manche sind da
capo
ich schiebe der brief will mehrere
projekte
gestoppt
wir sind ausgestiegen man hat seit
hausstaub fertig wir sind klein gemacht
sind
zum bundesendlauf marrakesch zum
verstehen dass man muss absagen
ja
sagt und ja es für trauben drehen können
das muss jetzt im nächsten
schritt mit herz wieder gespielt
dezember klick zusammenschluss herz und
das hat mich dann arno animax seit ich
muss ich muss da wieder zur ruhe
und von dem moment aber cornelia und ist
seit dem beschluss handschlag
ist es wieder weg sich nehmen
ich bin nah rief sie zur
identität hat natürlich ein witz
substanz um geld kostet sind paar
tausend franken sind für mobi ist
so ziemlich alle beruhigen sagen das
haben wir investiert in zukunft also
dass ich nicht alles verloren handeln
hofer trend aber man hat lehrgeld
cornelia und jean-marie sind nach
marokko gekommen um zu bleiben
diesen traum geben sie nicht so schnell
auf
[Musik]
in australien ist die lage angespannt
kehren die besitzerin des kamel hofs und
sabrina reden immer mehr aneinander
vorbei
markus blum ist ein friedliebender typ
er mag menschen und er ist es gewohnt
dass man auch ihn und seine ganze
familie mag
eine solch verfahrene situation ist für
markus völlig neu
oder
nein es ist nun auf
das gar nicht
franken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sein leben
[Musik]
und arroganz vectra
noch leben die händlers eine
traditionellere rollenteilung
während der vater das geschäft
vorantreibt kümmert sich die mutter und
die kinder vor allem der zweijährige
krimi braucht jasmins volle
aufmerksamkeit
[Musik]
das ist aber quatsch
das heutige mit sommerfest ist nicht nur
für die gäste der ferienanlage gedacht
sondern auch für die bewohner von
ölwerten die schweizer auswanderer
wollen zeigen dass sie sich heißt teil
der dorfgemeinschaft ziehen
das
ist richtig
[Musik]
aus
der fest brown ist fertig
keineswegs spd
frau muss nun einmal mit bahnhof stellen
[Musik]
finnland
als clijsters
[Musik]
herzlich
eine villa auf dem land wollen die
auswanderer nun mieten
bei den verhandlungen um die villa
zeigte sich dass das lehrgeld welches
sie bezahlten tatsächlich gut investiert
war
cornelia feilschte erfolgreich um den
mietpreis
[Musik]
die besseren
belehrt
in der schweiz könnten sie für dieses
geld eine zwei zimmer wohnung mieten
in marokko bekommen sie dafür eine villa
auf dem land mit viel umschwung
[Musik]
abdulaziz armut ist der besitzer und
vermietet ist anwesend
und hier ist der swimmingpool
stars am potsdamer
villa
in dieser wähler können die auswanderer
bis zu zwölf gäste beherbergen
[Musik]
familie mit kind
somit
ist
die attraktion der villa befindet sich
neben ihrem privaten schlafzimmer
ein hamam eine riesige villa zwei
zusätzliche gäste häuschen und doch ist
es nicht ganz das wovon die schweizer
einst geträumt hatten
die große jetzt eigentlich in absehbarer
zeit neue abschnitt los
ramacher
wirklich etwas machen dass jean marie
vor allem in der garage und
da in handwerk
stadtteil statt
im mai werde ich meine reifen werkstatt
aus der schweizer unterbringen lassen
und die erste fall für die ich baue
werde ich ihnen schenken
danke
[Musik]
in australien bricht die nacht an es ist
kurz vor der großen aussprache der blums
mit den besitzern der kamele trotz der
anspannung für die töchter amira und
nara soll es ein ganz normaler an sein
team befasst es oft aus vorbereitet
gejobbt eingerichtet so vieli kommen und
abstrich gemacht der heime show geplant
wieder und wieder auf einen punkt praxis
co wo man aus dem ganzen land kennt
finanziell wieder wieder leben und und
und ist weiter orientieren und wenn du
das jetzt einfach alles aber noch bei
102 das gefühl hätte man für
sie eine sehr gute
gekommen nachdem händler nein
werden sich sabrina und markus mit dem
kamel besitzern einigen können
wenn nicht wäre ihre abenteuerreise
schon vor dem start zu ende
[Musik]
freudig aufgeregt hingegen ist die
stimmung weil der familie henzler in
schweden bald kommen die dorfbewohner
und das fest kann beginnen
dann sollen alle erfahren wie die hotel
und campinganlage neue heißt
opfer
der name war jasmin cdm watch zu deutsch
nordlicht lodge
[Musik]
alternativ
bisher
wissen wir dass gerade deswegen jetzt
drücke mit der viel zu
wenig
[Musik]
berlin/mainz erfolge holen
gesine aus deutschland kann einspringen
[Musik]
glänze das in einer minute wir haben als
kassier ich habe gar kein portemonnaie
du machst mir jetzt sorgen nach fünf
minuten konnte der und rasten ein
verringern
es war eine lange aussprache in
australien mit einem positiven ergebnis
die blums kriegen ihre kamele
und
schlafe nachts
also zwar nicht rausgefunden dass
sich quasi glaubt mir würde die kommune
in den zug bringe meine dann hast du mir
extrem nicht so ist das rennteam
passieren
der reise steht nun nichts mehr im weg
im faszinierenden marokko droht einmal
mehr das schreckgespenst der bürokratie
im zentrum von essar ihrer wollen die
auswanderer den mietvertrag für die
villa aufsetzen lassen
dazu brauchen sie einen konzessionierten
schreiber eine art notar
der vertrag muss morgen durch die
gemeinde beglaubigt werden
[Musik]
schreibe darüber ob das nicht alles
schrieb das denkt also jetzt probieren
das nachdem eine andere
mit einem klima der kranich und
er hat die falsche tastatur
wird er an der macht
[Gelächter]
trotzdem auch in afrika braucht es
mietverträge
vielleicht klappt es ja morgen
[Musik]
schweizerisch pünktlich aber auch mit
einer prise marokkanischer gelassenheit
sind die beiden auswanderer früh am
nächsten tag unterwegs
[Musik]
hat das mit dem vertrag geklappt es hat
alles bestens funktioniert
ihr vermieter hat tatsächlich einen
geschriebenen vertrag in der tasche nun
muss nur noch die behörde ihr okay geben
einst war es kölliken nun ist dieser
urtiere neue wohngemeinde
kommen der eta
gott der schöpfer ließ
[Musik]
der bürgermeister persönlich nimmt die
beiden in empfang ist das ein gutes
zeichen
[Musik]
kaum sind die ersten gäste mit getränken
versorgt hat mix ein neues problem
ich muss noch die speisekarte schreiben
wie viele brauchen wir ich weiß nicht
die speisekarte muss max auf schwedisch
schreiben
die das lasse ich hoffe es im film ist
im hof vor denen
mache zum beispiel
das wasser ich weiss es nicht ist der
grad
der schlacht findet das nicht
das heißt mit somit auch thomas
kraft oder kunst
kunst
cox mit
portis muss
lance cove praktisch muss mit allen
mitteln
london lingo lincoln
[Musik]
dem ersten mit sommerfest in der noch
hier in lodz gegen zwei ganz besondere
gäste eine offizielle note thomas wieck
und thomas wörz berg die beiden teilen
sich nicht nur den vornamen sondern auch
dass bürgermeister an
doch als erstes spricht der schweizer
gastgeber
ein
platz für nico hat das cocoon
fantastisch
bekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auch wir möchten durch herzlich
willkommen heißen ich als bürgermeister
werden alles tun was politisch möglich
ist und ihren visionen zu realisieren
wieder einmal willkommen zu heißen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
endlich endlich ist der tag da heute
brechen die blues auf sie bringen die
kamele molly romanischen und ted zum
planwagen
[Musik]
auf ihrer dreimonatigen reise
hoffentlich blums auf wenig verkehr
[Musik]
ein schwerer weg
superstar marta
[Musik]
ich habe fertig gemacht da
wo mich
wachgerüttelt und darum noch ist der
vertrag schon auch
wichtig
dass schweizer nach italien ist für die
kleine gemeinde ein ereignis
entsprechend viel aufhebens wird um den
zuzug des schweizer paares gemacht
der bürgermeister hier präsident genannt
kümmert sich persönlich um sie
karriere beim kanton und ich schaue mich
um russland wir haben damit ist
gewichtig zeit für gewisse
bevölkerungsgruppen ist strange sie für
mich dass es jetzt aber zeigt
der bürgermeister samt und orange zeigt
den neuen gemeindemitgliedern den
wochenmarkt des dorfes
ich hatte auch mal ist in der schweiz
ich liebe diesen
[Musik]
damit
trügen dort findest du das beste gemüse
vom markt
gutes gemüse
mit den schaafs kittel das sind keine
schaafs kutteln das sind kugeln dies
auch
dieses urtümliche bunte leben die
freundlichkeit der menschen und nicht
zuletzt dieses nicht vorhersehbare das
waren gründe warum die aka was ich für
ein leben in marokko entschieden haben
das beste fleisch ist das ziegenfleisch
denn die ziegen ernähren sich nur vom
aga baum
für schweizer gibt es kaum ein besseres
land und seinen lebensabend zu
verbringen aus marokko
hier ist es so bist du gut zu den leuten
dann sind sie es auch zu dir
grüße auf deine frau herzlich von uns
zur vertragsunterzeichnung gibt es eine
traditionelle tasche hin
[Musik]
von den vier kamelen ziehen immer nur
zwei den wagen
fünf kilometer wollen die blumes heute
hinter sich bringen das sollten die
zugtiere lona un-mission spielen
schaffen
[Musik]
was
einmal mehr soll der trick mit dem
wasser helfen
[Musik]
zusammenhang
dafür
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
viel marokkanisches geld für die
mietkaution
doch einen hausschlüssel bekommen sie
nicht
abwechslung bringt einen arabisch kurs
[Musik]
mit vier kanälen sind die blumes
aufgebrochen doch jetzt haben sie nur
noch zwei
und einmal mehr sind die blues eine
attraktion
in schweden hat max große pläne das wird
die größte terrasse von madonna die
jeder sehen will und
die familie muss von ihrer katze
abschied nehmen
[Musik]
wieso
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge